5g is going to be tremendous a hundred
times faster speeds and 4G if not
quicker than that much lower latency a
quicker responsiveness of the network
and also all kinds of applications we
can't even dream up so we're just in the
early stages right now the wireless
carriers are doing some deployments in
major cities including Los Angeles and
we're hopeful that that's going to ramp
up in the future I think we're gonna
have 92 commercial deployments across
the country by the end of this year so
what's happening with 5g right now
because I think now in LA it's in
certain spots I am seeing 5g it just
pops up on my phone and I remember you
know I was traveling last year that
certain cities I would get it and I've
gotta go I didn't even know this was a
thing so how does that actually work
what you guys are trying to build a
nationwide network yeah so if I've G is
going to be tremendous 100 times faster
speeds and 4G if not quicker than that
much lower latency and quicker
responsiveness of the network and also
all kinds of applications we can't even
dream up so we're just in the early
stages right now the wireless carriers
are doing some deployments in major
cities including Los Angeles and we're
hopeful that's going to ramp up in the
future I think we're gonna have 92
commercial deployments across the
country by the end of this year many
more coming and so our goal is just put
the building blocks in place for
companies to innovate that involves
spectrum we're getting a lot more
spectrum in the commercial marketplace
held a big auction in January and other
one finished up in May the biggest
auction in American history is going to
be on December 10th and this year alone
we're gonna push more spectrum in the
commercial marketplace and is held by
every mobile broadband provider combined
when I came into office and so huge
influx of supply on the infrastructure
side too we're modernizing our rules to
recognize that small cells essentially
infrastructure that's no bigger than say
that basketball shouldn't have to jump
through the same regulatory hoops it's a
200-foot cell tower and that's the kind
of thing that has real pop here in LA in
particular just yesterday morning I was
visiting a site where they're deploying
these small cells in a lower income
neighborhood thanks in part to the
regulatory streamlining that we've done
and the city of La believe it or not has
done they have now have the regular
counseling you the city of may is
helping I've got to say mayor Garcetti
has been a terrific partner on this
issue other cities have raised a little
few more roadblocks but those cities
that are forward-thinking that want
their citizens to benefit from 5g or
adopting this more modern approach to
infrastructure deployment so overall I
think the United States is poised to
lead but there are other countries too
particularly China they would
to seize the lead for themselves and so
we're in an implicit competition I think
with many countries and regions around
the world yes so right before we started
we talked about this issue with how
China deals with regulation differently
and there there's strengths and
weaknesses to it can you explain that a
bit cuz I think it's it's a really
fascinating flip on the way we talk
about a lot of these issues
it is so China of course is not a
democracy Beijing can dictate not just
what Policy Priorities the government
should follow but also require all
provinces all localities to fall into
line and so of course since they don't
deserve the same Democratic niceties we
do in this case they can simply Fiat we
want to lead the world in 5g that means
we're going to pick the companies that
create the equipment and subsidize them
we're going to make sure that our
wireless carriers can deploy at scale
they don't have to jump through these
regulatory hoops and we are otherwise
going to take the steps necessary to
free up spectrum and do the other things
necessary for 5g success so that kind of
sounds good at some level right right
but there are of course some concerns
for those who share democratic values
such as the United States compared Italy
here we have not just federal regulatory
approval that's required state and local
regulatory approval that's required in
many cases but also under a
long-standing system that the FCC said
it many years ago any one of the 573
federally recognized Indian tribes also
can have a bite at the regulatory Apple
so one of the points I've made is that
let's try to modernize that framework to
say that there's a consistent level of
regulation especially if you're a
smaller company you don't have the
lawyers and accountants compliance
officers to jump through all of these
four different layers or review and to
the extent the capital is scarce and
work crews don't have to be hired in
networks don't have to be built I don't
want that innovative spirit to be
directed to other parts of the world
where you can deploy at scale and that's
part of the reason why we've been trying
to work with localities like LA to
update that framework to make it more
streamlined and just easier to cheaper
to build these networks so in effect
while China can just say alright we're
doing this and no local province can do
anything about it and and while that may
work for now like it may make the
process faster for now while you have to
deal with the local states and all that
yeah in the long term it probably hurts
their ability to innovate because it's
all coming from the top right you guys
have more of a slog to fight through now
but the hope is that you're creating the
the groundwork sort of to allow as much
competition as Potts
that through the cell companies
basically exactly right and part of the
reason why I want this regulatory
modernization is not just to be able to
compete with other countries but also
because we've recognized and this is one
of the truths that hardly ever gets
recognized in Washington that
heavy-handed regulation and multiple
levels of regulation disproportionately
affect smaller companies it's the larger
companies that don't have the compliance
freeze that have the compliance
resources they can jump through a lot of
these hoops and sure it will cost them
money but they actually have the
resources to comply we don't want to
squeeze out some of the smaller
competitors and especially in the
technology space we're trying to
encourage a lot more companies to enter
this space we haven't talked about space
itself yet satellite companies and fixed
wireless companies and some of these
newer companies they might not be able
to get off the ground if that regulatory
framework is so onerous that they can't
raise capital they can't hire the
lawyers and they can never deploy a
product yeah all right so I'm obviously
gonna want to spend a lot more time
talking about the pure tech side of this
in the Silicon Valley site which is not
as you said everyone thinks it's sort of
your job but it's not quite your job but
wait let's just do the the space thing
for a minute because now it's really
interesting because it quite literally
is the next frontier if not the final
frontier how in the world do you sit
down with people and you know you have
you have government people now trying to
deal with the ideas that Elan musk and
all these people are coming in with
we're privatizing a lot of the space
stuff how do you even come to a basic
place where you can say well you can you
can kind of do this and I want you to be
free but we can't totally do that I mean
how does that conversation even go it's
it's fascinating first of all it's just
intellectually fascinating to me I've
always loved space and the the
innovation that's happening in space
right now is just unprecedented I mean
the launches they're able to do using
reusable rockets have really decreased
the cost element to launching these
things into space you know I literally
sent to Tesla into oil just just because
he could do it like it's a product you
didn't have a regulation around that
that you can just send a car into space
there was no you didn't want to
yeah I didn't follow with the door
purview but certain other things to fall
within our purview so over the last two
and a half years that we were the first
administration to approve what are
called non geostationary satellite orbit
constellations ng SOS but essentially a
lot of satellites that are being
launched by companies like SpaceX and
oneweb and it probably cup or Amazon in
the future
hundreds are not thousand of these
satellites in low Earth orbits not deep
into space but lower in the Earth's
orbit so that they can beam internet
access services at a speed in a price
point they'd be comparable to what you
would get from a terrestrial provider
and my position here is very reflective
of those principles we talked about from
the beginning instead of preemptively
regulating deciding okay you can launch
but all of you know we're not going to
let you do it trying to pick a business
case or a business plan that's going to
work and letting them take the first
crack we're taking a more market-based
approach let's allow all of them to
launch it means various stages using
certain parameters for orbital safety
and whatnot and you'll see what happens
let's let the market the aggregated
decisions of consumers decide which one
will succeed and some of them might you
never know it could be a residential
broadband product some of them very
different they want to do industrial
Internet of Things I met recently with a
company that just wants to deploy 150
satellites around the globe and they
want to sign up customers like you say
the Department of Defense it has
military all around the world and they
just need essentially low bandwidth
services just to let people know where
the troops are at any given point in
time we want all of them to be able to
succeed in space and so yeah you don't
really think about the orbital safety
portion of this as you but happen so
that's just like no matter what happens
you guys almost always need another
office to open right I mean is that sort
of how it works
yeah all right I want them to put the
satellites up there we want to get
people internet as fast as possible and
as cheap as possible it's all good and
then someone probably walks in is like
you know we got make sure these
satellites aren't crashing into each
other and then you have to do what do
you do you do another study I mean do
you
what are you mapping out there that's a
good question so that's it goes to the
early question answer what if there were
no regulation so here is where I think
there is a base level of regulation
that's really important especially in
the space environment for those of you
who saw gravity as Sandra Bullock
exactly because that stuff lasts for
thousands of thousands of years
especially if they don't descend in the
atmosphere and burn up and so we want to
make sure that that space environment is
safe for everybody and so one of the
thing
I kicked off about a year ago let's see
how should we update our orbital debris
rules they were first adopted in 2004
but back then we didn't have a lot of
satellites up in space we're talking
about a lot more stuff in space and so
accordingly I think our orbital debris
rules need to be updated so we're in the
middle of conversation now about how
should we think about updating those
rules requiring companies to be safe
should they have 2d or '''but on a
certain schedule you set for in
technology that kind of things yeah so I
assume you'd prefer that everything has
some sort of like time limit up there or
something so that eventually that it
doesn't just become space garbage yeah
Futurama or something yeah exactly
because one of things we're thinking
about is truly a time limit shouldn't be
a built in technology so some of these
satellites can do orbit automatically
after a certain period of time or if
there is a failure they will
automatically deorbit things like that
and so ultimately we want to make sure
that everybody's can succeed in space in
the long run we don't want to like I
said in any of these orbital slots if
you have debris that's a generational
problem not just a multi-year problem
how much of this is sort of long-term
thinking say the way you would talk
about the climate change situation so
it's sort of like you can you can plot a
certain degree but no matter how much
you plot other countries I mean you just
reference China other countries are just
going to do things the way they want and
how complicated that makes your job its
meaning you do everything exactly
perfectly right and still if some other
country decides to do whatever they want
you still you still have all of those
problems it's that is a problem so
there's a lot of international
coordination that has to happen
especially when it comes to orbital
debris we're always working with some of
the other countries agencies to make
sure that we're all on the same page and
there are international organizations
that deal specifically with this in fact
shortly coming up and Egypt there's a
big quadrennial every four years they
have this conference and to talk about
spectrum issues and one of the issues is
what spectrum should be available for
satellite companies and so in that
context we're always talking about being
on the same page on things like orbital
debris and in spectrum allocation but I
think you raised a really good point is
that we could do everything correctly
but other countries are looking to take
the lead on things like artificial
intelligence machine learning or
blockchain or quantum computing and we
don't have jurisdiction over all of it
but to the extent we can we want to make
we advanced the US leadership because I
do you think that there are some first
mover advantages to countries and to
sectors that really show that they're
willing to take the lead if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about tech instead of
non-stop yelling check out our tech
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics check
out our full episode playlists they're
right over here and to get notified of
all future videos be sure to subscribe
and click the notification bell